good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the week
and weekend friday friday getting down
on friday
fun fun fun fun looking forward to the
weekend
good morning millennials happy friday
welcome back to the morning toast i am
back in studio we weren't sure if she
was gonna make it it was a yes it was a
no it was a remote it was taylor
strecker it was back to remote and that
[ __ ] got herself in studio
nipples charred we're here we're here
for it you're obsessed with my nipples
and i've actually been praised by the
mama community for being so um
caring and invested in your nipple
journey so for that mamas you're welcome
mama's getter
no everything is doing well there's milk
at home i'm excited to be here because
you know what it's actually we were
going to maybe do remote today but then
i was thinking it's actually maybe
easier for me to come to the studio
instead of worrying about getting 60
quiet minutes silence yeah so i'm happy
to be here well you don't know at home
won't kill you
instead of your business what's going on
he can cry
what like any time but not if we're
podcasting right right so now he can cry
for the hour if that's what he chooses
to do with his time so we just have a
few things to discuss first of all it is
friday our merch spring merch drop has
officially launched we've got crewnecks
hoodies sweatpants beanies mugs so many
things shopmorningtoast.com jackie and i
are both wearing the new 100 white crew
neck this also comes in blue but today
we both decided to wear the white
because we're just so simple
we are twinning from head to toe like we
wear our hair the same we're in the same
sweatshirt we're both wearing leggings
and we're both wearing air force ones
what brand are your leggings um they are
asos maternity they're so comfortable i
should get some i can't stop wearing
them i'm wearing dan's skin but from my
head to my toes we're literally matching
and i almost wore the same necklace the
two-tone one that claudia just got and
instead i wore this really sweet
necklace situation that says jackie o
and harry the cutest thing um but then
we would have been matching insane
except your part is like a little
off-center whereas mine's totally sad i
don't think so no you don't have like a
perfectly middle part
let me see
no it's literally not no i think it is
no i don't think it is actually i don't
think so
um so merch shopmorningtoast.com not to
be confused with chanel.com i know it's
very confusing for everyone um but also
we need to catch up because we kind of
dropped a bomb on wednesday's episode
just something we were thinking about
doing and we wanted this is the thing we
are a show of the people like we cater
to our audience most of the time to a
degree to a degree
but we don't succumb
and we wanted to get your input on
something you know we were thinking
about changing but we have heard your
cries good morning millennials is going
nowhere it is staying we hear you i
didn't say one message advocating for us
to change i saw like
less than ten yeah so i would say 99
are team gmm and
majority rules and as the old phrase
goes if it ain't broke don't fix it
agreed and if a new listener is
listening and like that's what to turn
them off then you know what like they'll
probably would have been turned off in
the next sentence anyway yeah they
weren't right or died when claudius
started singing a hundred percent are
going off about pitbulls you know what i
love about this sweatshirt that i wanted
to um
bring up i love the design because it's
so
smart because it says 100 sure but the d
sort of looks like an a so it's like 100
percent oh i also like it because the
shape of the font is like a heart
well duh yeah i'm saying like
thank you yeah no i didn't know if it
were right but that's like more
subliminal because i just have this like
really like um detail-oriented like
art-focused eye so i didn't know if
everyone saw that so i'm glad that like
you know we're all kind of my influence
on everyone is obviously making an
impact no but this is like giving like
fedex logo like
there's more that meets the eye hidden
message yeah in the design do you guys
know about the hidden arrow in the fedex
logo i always feel like so cool telling
people who don't know i'm like do you
know check it out like if you google
like best logos fedex is always number
one because there's an arrow in it and
it's like moving forward because they're
always moving your [ __ ] and amazon
with the arrow from a to z because you
can get everything from a to z which you
really can except for morning toast
merch which is only available at chanel
oh sorry me making my mistake again
shopmorningtoast.com yes so get yours
great for spring that sweatsuit has been
my lifeline the past few months and also
even before while i was pregnant i was
wearing it too but you didn't see um but
the last two months like all i wear is
that i can't talk about the pink
sweatshirt because i lost both items in
the river going on a walk pink
sweatshirt 100
100
um so we have an amazing show for you
guys today but it's going to be a little
different it's not going to be like
other shows upside down twisty turtles
it's opposite day it is opposite day
well i was picking stories because
jackie was obviously busy and then like
the stories that i chose are ones that
i'm actually like really like kind of
caught up on
so i just feel like the person who reads
the stories like should know more about
the story because the other person asks
the questions right like there's an aunt
and christina hack thing in here like
you really don't know much about that
and i need to know and i know you are
obsessed obsessed so i decided to do the
stories today which means my role of
being like saleswoman of the year
is actually going to jackie she'll be
doing our three abs today i will be
doing the ads you know i love doing the
ads do you well probably because i don't
do them every day but i really like to
get into them and these are three brands
that
they speak for themselves 100 percent
just like camera pro oh update on camera
pro we have not heard from them we have
not aside from just like the standard
they sponsor our show every once in a
while which we're extremely grateful for
you know great roi no but they are like
not commenting on our instagram or
anything and like they didn't even
notice our new instagram bio nobody's
noticed it yet go check it out i think
you'll enjoy it it's [ __ ] hysterical
um and i just can't wait to beat this
joke till it's dead no it's not getting
old and i'm never like i feel such
inspiration like i feel like when
michelangelo was doing the sistine
chapel like that's how i feel when i'm
designing on canva and it should come as
a shock to no one that camera pro is not
a sponsor of today's episode we just
felt like chatting about our favorite
products so get your [ __ ] ass up and
use camera pro um why do we say favorite
is it from fabfitfun yes oh my god
when we started our show like years and
years ago when we were the morning
breath our first week we used to never
do ads because we didn't have to worry
about revenue our show was owned by like
a media company so we weren't we were
just getting paid salary doing our show
right but we got an opportunity to get a
sponsor and it was fabfitfun so we were
like [ __ ] yes we had to go into like
this recording booth and record and we
just like could not stop laughing at the
script and we were doing it so many
times and it was like the fall seasonal
box yeah and it was like so many cute
items these are my favorite items and
when you say something just so many
times and i've never said the word
favorite yeah at the same ever again
yeah and so now it's my favorite blanket
it was like that shawl blanket thing or
like a seasonal kiss you know a favorite
maybe i got it from this but it's also
am i your favorite camper yeah but
camper was after right so maybe i got it
from that but i feel like that's how
most people would know it from ac's
amazing work amazing vernacular
huge vocabulary um speaking of
vernacular i just um started watching
abbott elementary have you heard about
it i've heard about it it reminds me of
the office you know they like look at
the camera but it's like the writing is
really funny but the best part i don't
know if i'm am i having deja vu have you
spoken about this not to me chessy
is one of the teachers at the school she
would be an amazing teacher an
amazing that's like a really great cast
but now she's probably getting typecast
in like these sort of
counseling roles well no she's like the
bad teacher
she like you know she's like a philly
girl she knows a guy like can get her
like you know free stolen school
supplies like she's like the bad teacher
is she bad teacher no no because she
really loves the kids she loves the kids
got it it's a really sweet show um would
you recommend to me
it was really hyped up
so like i always feel like a little bit
let down when a show is so hyped up but
it was pretty good i think you would
like it i have a hard time like focusing
is there good camper energy
it's more about the teachers there's not
a lot of camper energy
but the writing is very funny
i think you'd like it yeah maybe i'll
check it out it's on hulu i have so many
things to read right now we're recording
red hats next week it's never too late
to become a redhead ever so i'm gonna
spend my weekend reading when i have
free time but maybe next week um and
we're gonna do a little tv recap today
because we both watched a new episode of
the kardashians yes i'm so excited to
recap it's so many thoughts me too it
was a really good episode so i think we
should just dive in and get the show on
the road i think we should dive in and i
think you should let us in now that we
are roll reverse i agree
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
are you ready don't be nervous okay i'm
nervous but here we go i'm gonna start
with a personal favorite because today's
episode is brought to you by noom noom
understands that everyone's weight loss
journey is unique as claudia would say
and what works for someone else doesn't
necessarily mean it'll work for you
that's why noon uses a psychology-based
approach that adapts to your lifestyle
it's flexible approach focuses on
progress not perfection and allows you
to work towards your goals at a pace
that's comfortable for you so i
personally have been using noon for
years but now my lifestyle has changed
and noom is changing along with it you
know because i used to like now i really
need to eat every two hours because i'm
breastfeeding and neum suggests like
amazing snacks that are packed with all
the nutrients that i need but that also
are keeping me on track so whatever your
weight loss journey is nume is here for
you they use a psychological approach
which is different it's not like other
programs it's different from other
programs that you might have used so new
weight makes it easy to start on your
weight loss journey and stay on track
they have personalized lessons to help
you gain confidence with practical
knowledge you can employ right away more
than 60 percent of users engaged with
the program keep the weight off for a
year or more that is a big statistic
because as everyone knows with weight
you know you can yoyo if you're not
taking it off in a sustainable way
so noon weight is empowering and
flexible and you can start building
better habits for healthier long-term
results sign up for your trial at
noom.com
toast that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com
toast now i ask you what do you have to
lose
noon.com toast um really well done
really really well done i honestly
couldn't have done it better myself
should i do a twofer no we have three
yeah okay so just for now that's new you
guys check it out first story the
internet is rejoicing
james corden is leaving the late late
show in 2023. i don't feel like that's
what the internet was looking for the
internet hates james corden okay but
like that but just think about like him
leaving means he's free to do more
projects right i feel like the james
corden
hatred is when he's jumping into
everything yeah like the late late show
is james corden that's like saying james
corden is leaving carpool kairio because
it's not like i want someone else to be
doing it no no you're totally right and
okay so here are the details he's going
to depart ahead of summer 2023 so he
extended his contract for one more year
um and then by the time he leaves he
will have been doing the show for eight
and a half years which is a major
achievement and here's what he said it's
been a really hard decision to leave
because i'm so immensely proud of the
show i'm thrilled to be extending for a
year i always thought i'd do it for five
years and then leave and then i stayed
on but i've really been thinking about
it for a long time thinking there might
be one more adventure
so he addressed everyone like on
on air um and i agree with you like and
i'd like if you hate james corden like
him leaving your your nightly tv show
it sounds great but no like he honestly
couldn't do the thing that made him
famous anymore because he was being cast
as like this annoying character in every
movie every project every friends
reunion that honestly the show has just
become a burden to him now yeah and the
thing is like i'm someone who sometimes
complains like when james corden like
puts his spin on things but generally
speaking i actually really like james
corden i like his energy and of course
after the motivational speech he gave to
chloe um on kardashians i think
everybody's just like really become a
quarterfile and so
i look forward to seeing what he does
next but i think he was really great at
that show he was always like making
guests feel so comfortable and the
guests the celebrities love him
yeah yeah but see this reminds me of a
funny tweet that i sent you the other
day that i just want to share with the
group from zack silberg
i know exactly how i want to die i want
to get hit by the carpool karaoke card
so james corden will have to stop doing
it that is funny um but yes i agree with
you like i'm a person who gets annoyed
by james corden too but i've never once
gotten annoyed at him on his own show
right because i think the content i mean
him coming up well not him like his team
coming up with carpool karaoke he does
like all those great segments with
ariana the harry styles loves him i
think like the one thing he's actually
great at and is like universally
accepted at is his show right so this
doesn't bode well for the interesting
predicament james corden has found
himself in so late in his career yeah
and i feel like the people who are
annoyed by him it's not like they're
watching the late late show like wishing
he wasn't there like that's like saying
i don't like girl with no job like but i
watch the morning time right so stop and
that she's going to leave and then
finally i'll be able to enjoy this show
like no it's his show so i think for the
chord and the chord and phobics this is
not good news no you actually think that
it is right it's not it's a wolf in
sheep's clothing
but now it also begs the question like
who's gonna replace on the late late
show oh i'm sure they'll do probably a
woman because they're really okay but i
was thinking like because i you know snl
is like kind of a machine for
these lately like what about keenan
oh my god he would be amazing he would
be great at nbc like loves him they gave
him a sitcom i don't think he wants to
leave but then there's like no women in
late night i feel like that's what's
going to happen should
it be us
we can't say it's that late but like a
hundred i went back at 9 30 last night i
actually can't they pre-record though i
stay up so late they pre-record do they
i think so okay okay but like what women
woman
um i mean in like the nbc universe lily
singh the youtuber she got like a 4am
slot
um and it was received very poorly right
and i think you get the 4am slot to work
your way up to an earlier slot and i i
just don't think it was a fit i think i
saw a ted talk of her talking about that
experience like they filmed it wasn't
like
a current event show so they filmed 96
episodes in like a month and she said it
was like literally the worst experience
of her whole life and they were accused
of like stealing so many jokes um so i
just i actually don't think that that
but she came to mind first but i don't
know what other woman is like in the nbc
machine no but they could bring someone
in yeah but i feel like those jobs are
like ones you have to be in nbc for for
a while yeah
morgan stewart gave it to her
that's a good idea and she's nightly
she's an uh a nighttime girl or justin
or a child oh my god together he is like
boosting with talent but they like don't
know what to do with their true stars
like morgan and justin are like stars
and i feel like he like doesn't know how
to
take care like
harness fall foster foster that talent
yeah i agree also the fact that they
don't i mean i know morgan's on
maternity leave so the lollipop is ever
changing but they have not
solidified a third co-host since carissa
left right and they need to they need to
the viewers like stability yeah because
sometimes okay someone's hosting who i
like but sometimes someone's hosting who
i don't care about so like i need
stability yeah what about like
i know this just couldn't couldn't
happen because he already has a show but
like andy
yeah it couldn't happen because he
already has right but like i feel like
he's always wanting to do bigger things
yeah outside of bravo i mean and we're
saying like watch what happens live
really feels like it's on his last leg
because andy's so over it so i could see
um that would just be so weird to like
quit your late night show for another
late night show even though it's
obviously like a bigger network yeah but
it's later yeah it's later he could do
both
he barely wants to do the one uh let me
know who you think's gonna replace james
corden because i find that really
interesting and what do we think james
corden does next you know just more
musicals more musicals more cameos
more showing up everywhere doing
everything
maybe oh also i know we were talking
last week about um when downton abbey is
going to come out and it is coming out
may 20th yeah the suppression of downton
abbey has ended the censorship is over
it's coming out may 20th it already came
out in the uk
and i'm so excited and all the cast they
had like a big premiere in london and
they did like so much content on tick
tock yeah um it
was
splendid seeing the cast of downton
abbey in the wild is how it feels the
same as like the game of thrones which
we hadn't gotten in a while where it's
like they're so
different costumed up for the period
piece that when you see them in real
life and like they have their hair dyed
and they're wearing like lipstick which
didn't exist and big gowns like it's
crazy it was shocking no and it was
so good like i loved all the content
everyone looked great and like you know
i've been really hard on her
but major shout out to edith for
literally owning the red carpet like she
was the only queen on that carpet she
was the snatcher she was the stature she
looked amazing
um branson looked good too
i'm not a branson girl i'm a branson
file i think branson is so hot branson
is like scott disick
oh he is scott disick yeah yeah because
he's just like a part of the family
family for sure always will be and like
they just love him so they keep him
around even though technically like they
don't have to yeah and like he keeps
working with the family brings a lot to
the table so much like those pigs aren't
going to attend themselves definitely
not and i'm talking about like actual
pigs on the farm in downton if you watch
downtown that wasn't insulting and if
you don't watch showtime like there's
enough time now to watch it before the
movie comes out yeah do you want to tell
everyone why they should watch downton
yeah because like i was a downtown hater
like i was like i used to come on the
show and like i was watching downtown
for the first time i would recap my
journey claudia would roll her eyes and
be on her phone not listen to a thing i
had to say and then because like if
you're not a history girl which i'm not
like it's so easy to roll your eyes at
like historical pieces and the thing is
like i know nothing about history um
but
it doesn't matter because like the show
is just so good it's like a drama it's
like it's literally gossip girl right
and like right you're just watching the
drama but then you are subliminally
learning about history and like the
world war one the titanic right and you
know what um every time i'm watching
downtown like when i was watching in and
out they keep continuing the song i got
like we have to eventually get to the
holocaust right i know and like not to
be a hater but like holocaust content is
like so sad agreed just to cheer you up
like in the uk like they didn't get
it's obviously it wasn't like poland
they didn't get holocaust there but it
is world war ii and like
george and like george is probably going
to war right how is he gonna fare right
little sibby's cooking with rations
right how is she gonna fare right
makes you think it really does make you
think so what year what year was the the
movie was 1927 the first movie they're
supposed to go like 12 years yeah no
we're not gonna unless they keep going
for a really long time we're not going
to get to world war ii the dowager was
noticeably absent maggie smith is that
her name yeah in real life absent from
the pre premiere she's busy dude she's
busy but it is confirmed that she's in
the film she is in the film okay yeah
thank god thank god so she's not in the
film james corden
thank you for bringing it back to james
corden and you know what i wouldn't be
surprised if he had a cameo he's british
like honestly stranger things have
happened he would be great he would if
there was a musical number like i could
see that for him um okay next up is a
story like i'm particularly invested in
um it's the christina hack and aunt said
tarka who's the heather ray young
love rhombus um another major drama you
know christina got remarried she used to
be married to aunt einstead who's now
dating renee zellweger i know auntie
instead
and they had a baby together aunt and
christina
and yesterday and anstead requested full
custody like saying all these things
that christina is a terrible mother she
uses the child as a social media prop
and she's with her children nine days
out of the month like really vicious
whoa but a judge has denied his request
for full custody of the two-year-old son
that he shares with with ex-wife
christina hack that happened this
morning and his rep had no comment but
it's really messy like messier than
you thought that you think that the
ansteds can't go lower here they are
okay i feel like before i became a mom i
would have been like okay we'll see how
this plays out whatever but now it's
like she has to have be a really
atrocious mother for like him to get
full custody because he's like a really
vengeful piece of [ __ ] right because
like the way moms put everything on
their back like to take a child away
from a mom like that like
she has to be awful or
or like he just [ __ ] hates her and
it's because the judge denied it right
right like if there was actually
the child was in danger like she wasn't
making a safe space so that were
actually true the judge would have had
to approve it right so assuming he's
lying he's a colossal piece of [ __ ]
right she carried this child in her womb
and from her loins for 10 months you
tell them birthed him like the it's just
like
the nerve of these men the nerve of the
nerve and you know i have to assume he's
not telling the truth because
the judge denied it yeah like if there
was actually like insurmountable
insurmountable proof that like she was
making the home a dangerous environment
and
not proper neglect or whatever the judge
would have no choice but to grant
custody or at least temporary custody to
end yeah but
there was no proof i guess yeah and you
know what like in this whole love
rhombus if i had to choose one person to
like side with even though she's kind of
messy she's been married so many times i
think i would choose christina
because she was married to tarek and
i don't think tark was an easy man to be
married to
i think she put up with a lot and now
aunt is married to renee just dating
it's too much i don't know these people
i don't know the players enough to like
have a real opinion about them but i
think like taking a child away from
their mother full time is just wrong
unless like it's egregious and it
doesn't sound like it is but also
speaking of custody did you see about
olivia wilde i did and how she was
served papers custody papers and so me
and taylo and taylor has um when she was
hosting with me yesterday she actually
has experience serving papers because
she's been divorced and she tells you
exactly like you choose exactly where to
yeah where to do it so it could have
been really intentional or then after we
wrapped the episode i got legal experts
telling me if you have been dodging your
served like your papers that they're
trying to serve you they will go to any
means necessary to serve you so it's
possible that a jason snake has tried to
embarrass her on purpose and do it there
or she's been dodging these papers
and they had no choice but to do it in a
public place of work they're very
they've always been like a private
couple i don't even know how many kids
they have like they're very low yeah i
have to imagine this was a last resort
for him i agree
um but still that's a wild thing to
experience so
like these events like even if you're
you know d-list you can't get in how did
this legal messenger get into that
that's literally what i said i'm like
it's one of these huge las vegas
conference centers like there's security
everywhere olivia wilde's on stage i
don't know so he got like backstage then
i was asking taylor like if you're a
paper server man do you have like a
badge
i don't think it's that serious i don't
know but also like it's just this
business conference so someone handed
her an envelope like you know maybe it
was important paperwork for the panel
you know yeah but still how did he get
backstage he didn't get backstage he
literally walked up to the front of the
stage and like handed it to terms like
this is for you
interesting
that's crazy yeah that's really jarring
it is and she went on with the panel
like a pro so kudos there yeah for sure
so um the instead tarek christina and
her new husband um love rhombus
continues and we will always keep you
updated on this story because
they never sleep these are the stories
that matter and they never sleep
all right a little more reality tv news
mary fitzgerald is also claiming that
christine quinn lied about having
coveted have you seen this mary from
selling sunset yeah okay michelle okay
she's a one name wonder she's just mary
literally hate
so
the season wrapped and they were filming
a reunion this week and then last minute
christine was tested positive for covid
and couldn't show up okay which was
obviously very convenient seeing as how
literally she does not have one friend
on the cast okay and then christelle
came out and said that she thinks
christine is lying and then mary now
just came out and said chris she thinks
christine is lying and two days after
the reunion um christine did go to a
photo shoot okay um i haven't watched
the new season but i know that i'll
still be team christine because everyone
has the same personalities i'm assuming
yeah um but i also like saw something
that maybe towards the end of the season
it's like a little redemptive for
christine christelle so i'm only halfway
through but rachelle like starts acting
as terrible as christine like saying
just as bad like kind of things so i
feel like even though christine doesn't
have friends like she's always in that
situation and i feel like she
wouldn't shy away from an opportunity to
like let herself be known right and like
even i think a reunion setting would
actually come up really well for
christine because you could see how all
of the other girls are kind of getting
up on her so even if christine is wrong
about stuff like that's just never a
good look yeah um it's possible that
she's lying about having coven i
personally don't care i personally don't
care either and i just want to say like
one of the many blessings that came out
of the pandemic and not many one of the
few blessings that came out of the
torturous pandemic is like we all have a
lie that we can go to and like no one
can really question us because are you
want to question me having copied fine
i'll come into the office yeah no
totally you don't even have to like lie
and say you have code but you could say
like i have a cough like and i haven't
gotten a test yet do you still want me
to come right no i'm not feeling well
yeah and like if you're not feeling well
any sort of illness that you have stay
the [ __ ] home like that's the lesson and
that's what it always should have to be
covered for you to stay home because
there are things that are worse and more
contagious than covid two so even if
you've got a negative test i've heard
the notovirus doesn't mean you should
leave your house never heard of that
stomach bug
that's not a virus that's what they're
called it has a name it should be called
no no virus it should be called no
no
no
it should be called not again it should
be called
no
and i just want to say this is something
that i haven't shared yet um but when
claudia had the virus
she did bequeath it to me i did i did i
queefed all over the place i did get
that virus it was horrible my
initial experience was the same as yours
but then we took two different paths
like you stayed sick for a few days and
like um stomach issues i had like a
really um strong case anything like by
the time i pass it on to you i had
whittled it down no but like i had a
different case because i had 12 hours of
like really bad stomach issues and then
the next day i had a fever which you
never know yeah so but then so i had a
shorter experience but i think it was
more compact right did i also give it to
zach and then i bequeathed it to him it
was a really horrible few days and i
wasn't ready to talk about it until now
a month later yeah and i will totally
take responsibility like for giving it
to you but i do think like we shouldn't
forget who gave it to me and that's
ben's offer of course ben bears a lot of
responsibility but like you gave it to
me no i walked into your home with like
she came in with the virus sitting
dormant in my stomach she's texting
saying ben's not feeling well who wants
to hang out right she was like he has
food poisoning so she came over i was
like by the way like your husband's sick
are you bringing the sickness to our
house she's like no it's food poisoning
it's not contagious
i stand by that statement brought it
into the house i stand by that statement
if it was food poisoning it
hypothetically would not have been no
but it's like oh i'm not feeling well
let me go see my sister with her newborn
baby yeah well the thing is is like one
thing about me is that i'm a selfish
queen and it's like i'm on death's door
gotta see harry like
i just need to feel like i need to feel
skin to skin with harry we had so much
skin to skin yesterday yeah you got
really good cute oh my god he was like
in such a perfect mood like right after
his nap right before he ate like just
so delicious so perfect so big so big so
chunky so chunky like you guys these
cheeks not to rub it in because you'll
never see a photo of him like don't be
jealous um he's literally poo poo you
know knock wood
the
most gorgeous child i've literally ever
seen in my life like all the other
babies quaking
co-waking i never saw a kid like that in
my life like that's really perfect skin
i feel like everybody feels that way
about this no i've seen some ugly kids
no but like you don't know them no
everyone feels that way about their kin
no no because i know some kids i'm
related to who are plenty ugly
no you don't no i do
i do distant cousins you know not not
michaela or harry okay they could never
be ugly no but you know some kid you see
people on facebook like oh that's my
cousin's kid
no i'm telling you
um
half kidding
so
so thank you for requesting it to me and
harry was fine thank god but also that's
the power of breastfeeding those animals
oh my god they were working overtime
yeah yeah yeah that's true so we were
saying noni virus
christine so christine probably doesn't
have covet i just want to put that on
the record i also noticing like when
celebrities or inferencers are posting
like uh just had food poisoning it's
like no you didn't no you had the no no
you had the no no and then it just it's
the great equalizer like then you're
envisioning that them sweating
what you experienced yeah i'll really
never sitting on a heating pad i'll
never forget
um that time of my life like it was
especially the first three days like it
was
non-stop and like i'm screaming for help
like to ben like as if he can do
anything you know yeah no there's
nothing anyone can do for you
there's nothing you can even do for
yourself except i can't stress this
enough if you have to vomit sit on the
toilet like just don't ask questions and
just do it don't ask questions like
don't be like why just shut up and do it
okay
you'll find out soon enough um but
christine if you are sick we are truly
wishing you the best yeah we are and i
you know what like christine to me is a
queen like if she didn't want to go to
the reunion she shouldn't have to agree
but she shouldn't suffer these fools i'm
sorry no these are all losers and she
also is a new mom so like well not that
she's a year out now but like yeah no
her kids like seven but yeah i'm sure
she'd rather be home with her babette
than suffer these fools 100
um is there something you want to say
there is something i want to say because
before we get into the next story i
absolutely have to let you know that is
brought to you by third love and you
know what my life is brought to you by
third love right now because for third
love it's their 24 7 classic t-shirt bra
that is getting me through it's their
number one bra for a reason it offers
unparalleled comfort thanks to every
unique detail in its fit style function
and design it's loved and worn by
millions of women it doesn't pinch or
dig and you won't want to take it off
the moment you walk in the door right
now bra comfortability is probably my
number one priority in life and
love is here to support me in many many
ways the t-shirt bra is ultra thin the
memory foam cups give your boobs
everyday comfort and support the luck
straps never slip it is so smoothing it
looks invisible because that's my least
favorite thing when like the bra is like
poking out of the t-shirt you know and
you can just like see it
this one is so smooth and comfortable
it's giving it's firing in all cylinders
and third love is the place for bras it
just is you will love your fit
guaranteed if not exchanges and returns
are free for 60 days you will also know
that your fit is fitted to a t because
you do take a fit quiz where you answer
all of these questions about them
titties
and and third love hooks it up like they
know no one knows a woman's breast like
third love so true and ben they are also
the largest donor of undergarments in
the us they partner with organizations
across the united states so third love
has donated over 40 million dollars
worth of bras to help people in need and
you just love a company that also gives
back you do feeling is believing give
your boobs the 24 7 comfort and support
they deserve upgrade your bra today and
get 20 off your first order today at
thirdlove.com that's 20 off at
thirdlove.com
toast third love support them titties um
okay next story is like kind of some
devastating news to the momentum we were
already feeling with the new barbie
movie uh-oh aqua's barbie girl song
won't appear in the movie
wow come on barbie let's go party is the
immortal refrain oh my god
who who
is aqua
um from the 1997 song barbie girl but
when it comes to the upcoming margot
robbie movie aqua hasn't robbie i love
her she's amazing aqua hasn't been
invited to join in on the fun and
despite fans insisting that the euro pop
banger which has clocked up over a
billion views on youtube should appear
in the soundtrack to the mattel and
warner brothers film variety understands
that there are no plans for that to
happen the song will not be used in the
movie ulrich mahler jorgensen who
manages aqua lead singer lynnae nystrom
tells variety and variety reached out to
warner brothers for comment no response
um but it appears as though like they
haven't made any sort of
is there something funny that i know but
if orlando
that was a really good pronunciation i
just want to say if olaf meyer jorgensen
said it's not gonna be the movie it's
not gonna be it's ulrich first of all
and he manages um or she i'm not sure
manages awkward lead singer lennae
niestrom so yeah that means it's not
happening aqua has not been contacted
okay so you know what this means this
means an opportunity they have written
an original song that absolutely has to
be better otherwise it's a floppio
moment and i'm gonna be hopeful that
they didn't reach out to aqua because
they have a better song right like who
do we see even the whole soundtrack will
probably be like a moment who do we see
like i see a little mix on there i see
her
little mix right i love little mix so
much they're on tour right now madison
beer they're not coming to like the us
anything they're on like a breakup tour
no but they're like they're on a tour
they they said that they're taking a
break but they're still working like
every day but this is like their
farewell tour everyone i'm on i'm on
little mixed little mix talk yeah my
little mix ig and they're literally like
every show hysterically crying oh my god
they're so [ __ ] cute and like bring
the show to new york like yeah don't be
shy don't be shy don't be shy won't bite
you touch your love is enough to knock
me off my feet all week we'll buy the
tickets and by the way every time we
talk about little mix like some little
mix stan clips it and puts it on little
mix twitter and they're so kind to us a
little mixed twitter like we do a show
every monday through friday on youtube
come join our community and i just love
little mix with my whole heart there is
a little mix song for every occasion
like feeling sad little mix working out
little mix going to the club pregaming
little mix black magic
little mix and it's called black magic
and it's called black magic
take a sip of my secret potion imma make
you fall in love for a smile that can't
be broken oh my god i can replace
chassis one drop could be enough
boy you belong to me
i got the recipe and it's called black
magic and it's called black magic
and you ever see the music video there's
like this black fart following them
around it's gorgeous and like that's one
of those songs that should be on rolling
stone's top 100 of all time and the fact
that it isn't just like delegitimizes
their whole enterprise and what's the
song wings
these wings are made to fly
and i don't let nobody bring
oh and you know my favorite song is of
all time and it happens to be little mix
with like david guetta
this ain't a heartbreak anthem i don't
get like every time i'm at a club i'm
like put it on it's so good
there's so many good songs they actually
just came out with a song for like their
farewell album called in between and
they reference their own lyrics like
they've referenced when they got their
wings and like
all these like songs that are uh their
most popular songs so they're just like
musical geniuses i know like they are
going on hiatus whatever that means i
remember and i heard that one direction
so i don't know what that means and
there's plans for i think um jade is
doing solo music like it's
it's happening yeah but just even if
they never gave us another song like we
need to sit in what we have and
appreciate everything that they've given
their discography and i saw them doing
an interview just like about their
career as a whole because they really
are like ending their
time for now and the one thing they said
that they wish they focused on more is
like becoming bigger in america
girls yeah because they're doing like
arenas
all over
the uk but i think if they came here
they would do much smaller venues like
they're not yeah they would they're not
super well known yeah they're literally
they're the spice girls like they're
incredible also um and i think their
vibe is so much better without jessie
like it was clearly like yeah because
these three love each other sisters so
much also the song salute is just like
the most female empowering song shout
out to my ex you're really quite the man
you made my heart break and that made me
who i am here's to my ex
hey look at me now well i'm i'm all the
way up i swear you'll never you'll never
bring me down
i think we just harmonized i think we
did too um
so good so good where were we
um barbie oh so who do we think would be
little mix really would be good on the
soundtrack but who else like
would maybe like doge a cat yeah oh that
would be good
lizzo
yeah so i i hope that they i'm
optimistic me too i hope that it's a
thing don't let me down
don't let me down i hope that they like
make it a thing like how they made the
charlies angels movie soundtrack like i
hope that's like a huge part of the
launch yeah
yeah better name all right are you ready
for our fifth and final story that is
going to lead us into our tv recap of
keeping up the kardashians oh no sorry
the kardashians it's funny the
kardashian show it's called the
kardashian zulu it's called keeping up
um
well there's
more legal news because their trial with
blac chyna has come to an end but on the
final day like so much stuff happened
okay give it to me pete was there i
heard and like he embraced kim she
walked out gave him a hug maybe a kiss
and then they left together and it was
just like beautiful pete was also caught
hysterically laughing because
in their fine in their closing
statements the kardashian lawyer was
just really trying to prove how like
chyna was this abusive person and she
was like i mean who breaks a gingerbread
house because you know they have those
big fancy gingerbread houses and pete
thought that was hilarious that is
really funny but then also really
interestingly is that
before the final statements blac chyna's
lawyer and by the way blac chyna's mom
has been barred are you okay you choking
just a little bit of wrong pipe action
okay you never know with you so
take your time i'm okay
um you know blac chyna's mom was
banned from the court she was literally
standing outside talking to paparazzi
but she couldn't go in um but before the
closing statements blac chyna's lawyer
asked if china could redo her 11-hour
testimony
and when asked why she said because they
had to bring into evidence the vagina
picture um which i'm sure was actually
really awkward and embarrassing for blac
chyna and she said like she couldn't
focus on the testimony after that and
like really threw her through a loop so
she'd like to redo her 11 hour testimony
and the judge said no got it i saw that
she was not pleasing she wanted to redo
because she was like shooketh from all
of that but all that was in discovery so
she knew it was going to come up and it
was on instagram like rob put her no but
like you prepare for a trial like you
know what's coming you know what you're
going to be asked about anything that's
going to be submitted as evidence like
both sides already know yeah so and not
to say that it probably wasn't extremely
awkward but like
you you prepare for that right or you
shouldn't
right so they said no and this is over
and i guess we just wait now we wait and
see
so i don't know i'm still a little like
fuzzy on the details in terms of like so
she
is suing them but they're also
countersuing her so is this the same
trial or they have to go to another
trial for the counter sue i don't know
and it's also like 100 million dollars
right so i don't think blac chyna is
going to win like i think that they
provided enough evidence to prove that
rob in china was canceled for a million
reasons not because the kardashians
didn't like her but because she was an
extremely abusive and like scary person
right and also it was rob in china and
then they were broken up right so
therefore there is
china right that's such a good point as
well
um but i love that pete was there for
her
yeah really sweet um even though after
this most recent episode of kardashians
colin jost are you shipping no you're
going to say i'm like really back to
loving kanye and like how he would do
anything for his family
part of me like my heart breaks a little
like
watching that on tv and then in the same
week he was sharing the live photo of
her and pete kissing at john and
vinnie's you know yeah okay that's very
true i was just shipping kim and colin
joseph because did you see the challenge
did i see those arms i
feel like any time colin jost is spotted
in a t-shirt which isn't a lie because
he sits behind that desk and his suit
and tie
but any time i see him in a t-shirt
which now is only the second time it's
shocked i am reminded of what a
beautiful man he really is
and i agree that scene at zero bond just
like that angle the light that we're
reflecting off of colin's t-shirt it was
it was something else and like the
height difference between kim and colin
but if i didn't love colin and scarjo so
much like i would chip but i my brain
doesn't love
i was like
makes you think that's the cool thing
about single kim like any person she
talks to i'm like a ship
interesting factoid ship i'm about to
start shipping her and simon like that's
how yeah right totally um okay so let's
dive into the tv recap and can you just
do me a favor and tell me who the tv
recap is brought to us by i can do that
because it is brought to you by
ziprecruiter according to the latest
research 90 of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022 after all a happy
workplace is key to attracting and
keeping great employees
having happy employees is the key to
success
so you can make employers employers can
make their employees feel happier by
making them feel more valued focusing on
company culture a bunch of different
things and if you need to add more
employees to your team there's
ziprecruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
zippercuter uses its powerful technology
to find a match and the right candidates
for your job it is so important to find
it's like you know are you the one it's
got to be a perfect match 100
then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
the recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster no
wonder ziprecruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the us based on g2
ratings so find the right employees for
your workplace with ziprecruiter try it
for free at this exclusive web address
are you listening
ziprecruiter.com
toast that ziprecruiter.com
toast
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire and to find people who are gonna
get their [ __ ] ass up and work seems
like no one wants to work these days
that's why you gotta get on zip
recruiter really beautifully done jackie
congratulations for making it through
all three you really you killed it
congratulations on making it through the
stories thank you okay so let's dive in
keeping up season one episode three the
girlies are in new york they're really
dragging out saturdays like literally
the whole episode was one day i'm not
complaining because they're giving us
more of the things that we love that
they didn't think that we would love
like they were giving us back in the day
like stories of let's adopt a monkey and
see how it happens now give us chloe and
glam love to see it chloe is really
shining and i have to say like
these first couple episodes have really
been about kim
and courtney like courtney and her
engagement kim in this big moment in snl
and you can chloe's such a good sister
because she's so genuinely happy for her
sisters when she said to chris like
chris you're a boss [ __ ] you're giving
birth for a legend for giving birth to
the boss ass [ __ ] that is she's so
happy for her family and she so like
lifts other people up and i think a lot
of people might feel like jealous or
like you know insecure like why isn't
this about me and i think that's a
normal reaction for people but like
she's so genuine in the sense like
crying so happy for courtney crying so
proud of kim like everyone needs a
friend a sister like khloe kardashian
it's so admirable to see like a woman
who really actually not even in a joking
way is out here supporting other women
yeah i was watching it and um that's
funny that was your takeaway because the
way i was feeling like i feel like kim
and chloe remind me so much of me and
you yeah yeah yeah like because one
they're like talk all the time they're
so close like kim is always shining you
would be the kim in this situation like
you're always
doing big things you're always putting
yourself out there and chloe is just
like so genuinely supportive and that's
how i feel about you like chloe is
really kim's number one fan and i really
feel like i'm your number one favorite
and so nice and i just feel like the
dynamics of their family it's always
been like people would be like who's the
who and your family whatever i i feel
but i feel like on a personality level
it's maybe a little different like i
feel like my personality is very similar
to kim yes and you are very like chloe
like you're magnetic everyone wants to
be around you your life of the party oh
my god i'm loving this conversation kim
is just like very logical very calm yeah
that is more so hundred percent i feel
like in their relationship they remind
me so much of you and i even how they're
always with chris it's always like we're
so close with our mom totally we're all
just like
talking about that's so true like
talking about the rest of the film
talking about the rest of the family
like helping everyone make decisions but
like travis needs to help propose like
that's literally the three of us with
shapiro by the way shapiro and olivia
are travis and courtney 100 like so in
their own world obsessed with each other
and then margot is a combination of
candidates
yeah like doing her own thing such a
great little sis but like you know
taking on the world kylie like driving
with her stacks and saying she was gonna
vomit like that was reminding me so much
of you that was our mukbang yeah
and why didn't they show us i'm eating
the burgers i know like we would have
loved to see that um but i really got
like extremely choked up during the
laptop scene even though like i knew
what was coming first of all seeing him
crying kim is so funny finally allowed
herself to cry right i've never seen
someone with such control over her
emotions like the way she literally
wills herself to stop crying when she's
wearing makeup and then she's like
getting choked up she's like oh wait i'm
not wearing makeup and totally allows
herself to break down that scene was
like so
so special and it made me so sad for
like how
much things have changed
till now with kanye um
but and i know he did it like for kim
but he really did it for his kids and
his family to protect them but it was so
sweet and like that's why he flew coach
yeah no it was a gorgeous moment it was
really nice to see kanye again on this
show and i'm just so glad that like it's
over for kim like i i could feel what
she was really and to get that relief
right before this big major event snl
like must have been just the best
feeling yeah and i didn't know that like
for all these years it's like weighed on
her so much like i assumed like the tape
came out and like that was the worst of
it but just knowing like there was more
stuff that someone else had she didn't
have it yeah or that someone out there
there was more stuff like she didn't
know what the more stuff was but that's
just hit inducing and now i'm dying to
know how kanye got it back if he without
money
right i
i think he maybe just wielded his power
as [ __ ] kanye west yeah and ray j who
like is a little [ __ ] but like it's not
dumb like i don't think connie is the
type of person you want to cross yeah
it was really really special and i'm
glad that she allowed herself to cry
because i feel like all the times like
even when alice johnson was released
from prison she was at that photo shoot
and she couldn't cry and we always see
her like holding back her tears but
we've never and aside from when she
divorced chris humphries like i really
never seen her like cry about something
like so deeply emotional and
it was beautiful to see her cry it was
beautiful and i actually thought
something else really interesting first
of all that dinner at milos looked just
gorgeous um
and chloe was like they always like rag
on chris for like always crying and
talking about the old days but i
understood what chloe was saying she's
like our life is so amazing right now
like mom's always missing it because
she's thinking about you know when she
was a flight attendant and she's like
crying in the corner and then you know
in 20 years she's gonna be thinking
about this dinner but she wasn't even
fully present yeah so like i thought
that was shapiro for a second outside
outside it looks nothing like him like
not even well the way that the lights
are i can't really see it actually yeah
just a silhouette i think i was like
shapiro you've heard how to surprise you
um i agree but also i feel like chris
hasn't gotten the memo that this new
show isn't about antics because her
running around fifty seven straight
apartments right but her and corey
walking through the streets with like
all these cameras and like these people
being like what is going on was no a
little cute but like the antics have got
us happening you know she was trying to
rope chloe into going with chris is the
antics queen 100 percent she needs to we
don't need antics like crit like even
you just sitting around with corey
that does it for me corey was such a
star i completely agree he was the star
of the episode i love him and i know
that they're i think they're going to
cover it there's like some rocky road
ahead for them what do you mean
there was like a video going around of
corey what yeah being unfaithful no yeah
was it real yeah he was really
unfaithful yeah in pr in current times
in current times
since when i've never heard of it i
don't know but i like how corey like
matches chris's energy like he's letting
his gray hair grow out like i think he's
trying to age himself no because he is
just like the man of everything i'm
obsessed with i'm obsessed with him i'm
obsessed with their relationship i'm
obsessed with like the girl's
relationship to him i think it's so
beautiful and i really like love travis
even though we haven't even seen him we
just talked him on the phone i love how
much he respects the family how he he
went to kim and chris yeah he went to
the grave he went to the grave he's
really like a stand-up guy i'm actually
so happy for courtney like he even
though he's like this punk rock king
like is a little chubby yeah and he was
like i want to do it on the beach in the
shade okay with a tea and a keg
chugalicious not what i would expect
he's not like other drummers he's
traditional in a sense yeah really
really cute um so it was really good i
love seeing like their workplace like
kylie cosmetics office i just love the
little details of things we don't
normally see
and my only complaint is that it's a
little slow even though what a
star-studded zero bond after party i
want to talk more about that but that's
not what i expected in snl after party
to be like everyone kind of just like
sitting around getting drinks okay so
i've been to one and
for luke combs i forgot who the guy was
it was uh
oh luke oh it was um jay jay watts is
that his name
so it was the same vibe but like at a
much less fabulous location it was like
this random [ __ ] bar in like
hell's kitchen i'm so obviously for kim
they glammed it up zero bond for those
who don't know
sickening members gets to choose sort of
i don't think so but i think for kim
like it was such an affair yeah that
like and also when she comes to new york
she only goes to zero right
so um i don't think they're all as
glamorous as that but the energy is
still very much everyone grabbing drinks
and sitting at tables got it cute i
always thought the snl after party was
like a rager no i when i went i was like
oh this is cute like couple of people
like me mocktails with the covers
were like bored we were just waiting for
luke like yeah that's what it looks like
very low-key
it was like when they talk about the
after party i thought it was a razor
because they do work very hard all week
and i do think that this show has given
me more of an appreciation for how hard
the snl cast is completely did you know
we're always like they work one day
right um definitely we were
we were wrong just saying yeah no you
were wrong they work very hard on that
day yeah and in the days leading up yeah
and it's i'm sure a very stressful job a
great day and so every week they
decompress with an after party yeah that
works the way chris rock like just
respects the hell out of him like
obsessed obsessed the way kim respects
the hell out of bone yang
yang when he was like you want to take a
picture it was literally us olivia koba
you recognized me
that was so cute i love bow and yellow
who was wearing sequins on the show
there's did you just find a sequin on
your chair
on this table i've been playing with it
let me look at our instagram to see who
wore pink sparkles i don't think anyone
where'd it come from not paige not
stassi not remy natasha not ben
mysteries not joey camasta
not i mean paige is wearing pink but no
there's not a sequin in sight very
interesting is somebody using our studio
to have an affair someone's been here
ben
um not a single person okay i just went
through all the guest co-host pictures
now this is a mystery this is a case for
the fbi it really is
um okay i think that's our show right um
yeah that's our show i feel really good
about it being our show and no one else
100 100 and don't forget to get your
merch at shopmorningtoast.com
there's um
limited sizes so make sure you just get
over there scurry on over
shoppmorningtoast.com if you're looking
for pictures or size information like
head over to our instagram we have
pictures of us i wear xl i'm wearing
these and everything the medium on me at
this stage in my life is fitted um but
everything fits i would say true to size
this sweatshirt the material and such is
similar to the last hundred percent drop
that pink sweatshirt not the green one
the pink one is a similar um thing the
toasty crew neck most of our sweatshirts
are this material and i wear excel in
every crewneck so i would just go with
whatever crewneck
size you already have yeah but i would
say true to size because i have a mature
medium these days and thank you guys for
an amazing week jackie thank you for
making it in i know it's tough for you
we so appreciate you and we appreciate
you guys have an amazing weekend we'll
see you on monday thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the first live stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
your
morning toast today's episode no wait
i'm i'm rusty i'm short circuiting oh
but also thank you for circuiting
because there's also an amazing new
episode up on our patreon yeah you're
feeling really sad that this episode's
ending you're like i want my girls and i
also want them to be a little more
unhinged right go to patreon.com social
morning toast there's a new podcast
episode it's deer toasters all of it and
we are it's relationships edition
relationships edition and we are not
holding back no i would say like we
recorded it i would say we're holding
front we were recorded it when we were
extremely over tired yeah and
overzealous
and we are not holding back so get over
there check it out plus you get all the
episodes like 200 plus episodes you've
ever done and the second last one we
done was my first tasting of spritz oh
yeah so there's so much good content on
the patreon this month check it out plus
there's an interview with becky and dana
from the redheads we're talking about
like how we became friends we're sharing
some college stories talking about books
why we started the redheads and it was
just like fun you got a sneak peek into
my friendship with them
thank you so much for listening to the
morning testimony morning show we're
dealing with the fastback stories they
need to know every morning monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up or subscribe podcasting
spotify just teach your public radio
everybody can catch up to the places
where there's about as fast as we're
just faster than you about a beautiful
sparring have an amazing weekend we'll
see you guys on monday goodbye
you